hello everyone there are a lot of games
in chess history that could compete for
the title of the greatest blunder and
some people say that that kramnik game
against Fritz where he missed matin one
is the greatest blunder ever but I
actually preferred this game as it's
played between humans it was played in
the 1994 Linares tournament this was
actually the round before my previous
video where a Karpov created that
immortal game against Veselin Topalov
this is round two and the Karpov has the
white pieces against afghani Barea and
well this is a this is quite
unimaginable that almost a 2700 player
could could place such a move well it's
not unimaginable as the world champion
Kramnik did miss Mayton one but well
you'll just have to see the game and I'm
interested what is your favorite blunder
and do you think that this could be the
greatest blunder in chess history so
let's see the game
Karpov already won one game and this is
round two he plays efore beriev goes for
six d4 and d5 the French defense and
nice the d2 by Karpov the tarish
variation probably probably avoiding
Knight c3 and Bishop to b4 so instead
Knight 2 d2 and we have C 5 and the
Karpov immediately goes for the
simplification in capture send e5 e
capture son b5 and Knight to f3 Knight
to f6 by BA Rev and Bishop to b5 going
for even more exchanges and straight
into the endgame Bishop to d7 Bishop
capture son d7 would check Knight
chapter 77 and Karpov castles Bishop to
e7 a beriev is preparing to castle and
we have d captures on c5 Bishop kasoori
Knight captures on c5 and now Knight to
d4 and well okay maybe castling here
would be a bit premature by bereave as
Karpov maybe maybe we could play Knight
to f5 and this would be a pretty strong
square for the knight so Maria plays
Queen to d7 not allowing Knight to f5
and the Karpov goes a knight to f3
now this square is available for his
other night
Mariah castles and we have Bishop to f4
careful karpov places this Bishop on
this beautiful diagonal also his winning
the e5 square and brave goes rook FTE 8
we have rook to e1 and now Karpov is
completely owning this a 5 square Bishop
to f8 offering a trade of rooks and we
have 9th to e5 by Karpov Boroff has a
couple of options here he can play as
his queen is attacked he can either go
Queen d8 even Queen to c7 as possible as
Karpov doesn't really have any good
discoveries with the night but Berea
plays a queen to a4 and well
Karpov doesn't mind he plays c3 now
protecting his knight on d4 and also
offering a trade of Queens on D 1
because Karpov is saying well you do
have an isolated pawn here on d5 if you
want to exchange Queens I will have both
my rooks on a nice central squares and I
will you know I will play against this
d5 pawn and well this is a small
advantage but I'm Karpov this is this is
enough for me
Burrell declines the Queen trade he
plays Queen to a6 and here if Kasparov
played this position for example with
the white pieces I'm sure he will go for
something like rook to e3 a nice truck
lift followed by rock to g3 but as this
is Karpov playing he goes for Queen to
e2 again offers a trade of Queens and
this is this trade of Queens is a bit
more acceptable for bereaved and then
the previous one as this one doesn't
bring Karpov rockin a1 into the game
sober I have captures the Queen Queen
captures any two rook captures any to
end we have Bishop to d6 and well Karpov
now plays a move it's it's a tactic that
pretty much transfers the game
completely to the end game he plays
Knight to d7 and the move seems a bit
weird as now it seems like the beriev
can capture carpools night as it's
unprotected and also he can capture
Karpov the bishop here on f4 that it's
also unprotected
but not really if beriev captures the
bishop on f4
Karpov captures this night and ac5 and
if brave captures night
Karpov captures the bishop on d6 so it's
simply just a trade of pieces Bishop
captures on f4 by bereave and night
sorry first a trade of rooks rook
captures any age with Czech rook
captures and now Knight captures on c5
with an attack on this pawn on b7 and if
you look at the position both players
have six points and well the pieces are
the same only burov has a bishop against
the night and well carpets mean well
this bit of an advantage that Brazil has
this isolated D pawn so Bishop to c7 and
Karpov plays Knight to d3 the brave
isn't really worried about Karpov
capturing this pawn because if you
capture it Ruby 8 and after night the c5
wrote capture some b2 and this is
perfectly fine for black black has this
beautifully active rook
so after Bishop to c7 Karpov instead
played in Knights to d3 Bishop to b6
Knights the b3 and King to f8 rook to d1
and Karpov is preparing to create some
sort of an attack against this d5 pawn
we have a 5 and now it seems that Karpov
can play for example Knight to f4 and
well pile up on this isolated D pawn but
this wouldn't really be a good move
because if Knight a 4 but I have
prepared this a4 move and after night
study 2 you get Knight g4 now wouldn't
wouldn't attack on this f2 pawn and this
position is is is much better for black
so after a 5 Karpov decided to play King
to f1 now isn't this pawn isn't pinned
anymore he can push it to f3 too you
know restrict this knight on f6 rook the
c8 and we have night 2 D 2 a 4 now a 3
because bereave was threatening to push
a3 himself to undermine the c3 pawn so a
3 by Karpov and g5 expanding on the King
side also maybe limiting this the moon
of this night and III Knight to f3
attacking the g5 pawn and we have g4 now
kicking the night away Knight to h4 by
Karpov and carpel will now have this
strong f5 square for his Knight but by
gaining this he allowed black to push d4
and now black is getting rid of his
isolated pawn and this well doesn't it
doesn't look like something Harper would
allow but okay see capture sandy for
Bishop captures on d4 and nice to f5 now
the night is controlling placed in this
beautiful f5 square black has a dark
square bishop so he can't really kick it
away from there it's well if Karpov
thought that this was compensating I
believe Karpov Bishop to b6 getting the
bishop out of the way and night the b4
and this Knight is also placed very
nicely as this rook on the C file is
unable to infiltrate White's position
Knight is guarding C two ponies Guardian
C three rookies guarding c1 so it's a
pretty nice position for a square for
the knight Knight to e4 brave now
attacks this f2 pawn and well this was
something
Karpov had planned that's why the king
moved from g1 to f1 now Karpov has this
f3 move and well this this well has has
its upsides and also hits downsides the
upside is that after G captures an f3
and G captures an f3
Karpov kicks this night away from a nice
central square but the downside is that
well now the position is both players
have isolated F and H bond on the Kings
side and both players have two pawns on
the King side so this is pretty much
pretty much a drawn endgame nice the c5
and we have H for my Karpov we have R up
to the 8th bereave offers a trade of
rooks and a Karpov plays rook to d5 and
it's it's in this position that that the
drama begins this is the shocker as well
like I said it's a it's a pretty drawing
endgame bar F can simply capture this
rook and he has a bishop against the
night and it's the game is played on
both sides of the board he can't lose
this he can well if Karpov doesn't play
the best moves he can maybe even win
this but bereave plays which I consider
to be the greatest blunder ever played
in a top GM game he plays a bishop to a7
and well only a few seconds pass Karpov
grabs his rook and plays rook captures
on the 8 with checkmate this is
completely overlooking this rook and the
8 and this was a classical game it was
you know a normal time format it wasn't
the Blitz or anything
the knight is covering a 7 and g7 the
King can go anywhere it's game over and
it's really it's really hard to imagine
how almost 2700 player could make a move
like Bishop to e7 so some people say
that some people say that the bereave
probably already played in his mind rook
captures on d5 Knight captures on d5 and
then Bishop to a7 he thought that this
trade of rooks already happened on the
board and he was probably why he played
Bishop to a7 it's I don't know but this
didn't happen on the board on the board
he played Bishop a7 and Karpov check
made it his opponent with rook captures
and e8 checkmate
so yeah I'm interested how do you like
this game I mean do you consider this to
be the greatest blunder ever and do you
think it's it's it's it's a bigger
blunder than what Kramnik played against
fritz and maybe you have a third or a
fourth or a fifth option that you would
make a candidate for the greatest
blunder ever so yeah that's the game
this is round 2 of the 1994 Linares
tournament in the next round
Karpov will create his immortal game
against less elite Apollo as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
that one of them will be Karpov
immortal game against Veselin Topalov so
you can check it out if you haven't and
I would like to thank Samuel Kowalski
Liam fields ben shapiro and eric
ciminelli for a contribution to my
channel
I think a lot I really appreciate it
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon